bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero el
anuncio de suecia y finlandia sobre su
postulación para entrar a la otan ha
supuesto un giro histórico en la
política de neutralidad de estas dos
naciones durante décadas siglos en el
caso de suecia estos dos países nórdicos
se han mantenido alejados de cualquier
conflicto o alianza militar incluso en
los momentos más tensos de la guerra
fría en la crónica de historia de esta
semana repasamos los orígenes y el
desarrollo de esta política neutral en
ambas naciones y como la invasión de
rusia a ucrania ha contribuido a su fin
las causas de la neutralidad sueca y
finlandesa son bien diferentes en su
origen en el caso de finlandia esta
postura surgió tras la segunda guerra
mundial después de que la unión
soviética y finlandia se enfrentarán en
la guerra de invierno esta operación
militar soviética lanzada en noviembre
de 1939 tuvo el objetivo de conquistar
toda finlandia pero fracasó
estrepitosamente por las condiciones
climáticas los errores en el mando
soviético y la tenaz resistencia
finlandesa en marzo de 1940 se llegó a
un armisticio y aunque rusia logró
obtener hasta el 10% del territorio
finlandés la imagen de su poder militar
se mostró vulnerable de hecho apenas un
año después de este conflicto finlandia
se sumó a la alemania nazi para formar
parte de la operación barbarroja contra
la urss llegando a recuperar todos los
territorios perdidos pero aunque hacia
el final de la segunda guerra mundial se
unió a los aliados el país nórdico
finalmente se vio obligado a aceptar la
pérdida de estas regiones es en este
momento cuando se decide poner en marcha
la conocida como finlandia
o neutralidad en el contexto de la
guerra fría
finlandia pudo conservar su
independencia política y económica con
respecto a la urss a cambio de no
alinearse con ninguna alianza militar y
de mantener relaciones cordiales con los
dos bloques este status funcionó incluso
en los momentos más tensos de la guerra
fría y contribuyó al desarrollo de esta
nación tras la caída de la urss lo
acordado o venció pero desde este país
nórdico se apostó por continuar con esa
neutralidad teórica aunque en la
práctica se abandonó cuando la nación
ingresó a la unión europea en 1995 por
otro lado la neutralidad sueca viene
desde un punto mucho más lejano en la
historia aunque se vio de una forma más
voluntaria su estatus neutral se
consolidó tras las guerras napoleónicas
de principios del siglo 19 suecia tuvo
en numerosas pérdidas territoriales tras
este conflicto entre ellas la posesión
de finlandia por lo que tras este
fracaso optó por una política que
fomentase la neutralidad exterior ante
futuras guerras
una cuestión que con matices se ha
cumplido desde estocolmo a pesar de los
enfrentamientos bélicos sufridos en el
continente europeo su momento más
crítico quizá fue durante la segunda
guerra mundial donde suecia consiguió
mantenerse neutral a pesar de los
constantes desafíos lanzados por la
alemania nazi aunque es cierto que
suecia se vio obligada a ceder en varios
momentos de la contienda a las
exigencias nazis para evitar una
invasión alemana y la entrada en la
guerra por ejemplo suecia permitió el
paso por sus fronteras de soldados nazis
y colaboró de forma puntual con berlín
pero jamás se vio obligada a desplegar
tropas la victoria aliada hizo que
suecia volviera a una neutralidad más
formal aunque desde estocolmo nunca se
ocultaron las simpatías preferenciales
hacia el bloque occidental pero lo
cierto es que a diferencia de finlandia
donde prácticamente se impusieron unas
relaciones exteriores neutrales para
evitar una agresión de la urss en suecia
sí que hubo una voluntad real de ser un
país alejado de la carrera
armamentística que se vivió durante gran
parte de la guerra fría
tras la caída de la unión soviética
suecia comenzó un proceso de desarme que
duró hasta finales de la década de los
2000 cuando esta nación comenzó a
invertir de nuevo en material militar
esto fue especialmente notable a partir
de la anexión de crimea en 2014 por
parte de rusia debido a un temor a
futuras acciones de moscú suecia además
rey instauró el servicio militar
obligatorio entre sus jóvenes y comenzó
a colaborar de forma más estrecha con la
otan hasta convertirse en un aliado
preferencial de esta organización es en
este contexto en el que se llega a la
actualidad donde tras el ataque de rusia
a ucrania los dos países decidieron
postularse a entrar en la otan algo que
supone un duro golpe para el kremlin ya
que precisamente uno de los factores que
llevaron a la invasión de ucrania era la
amenaza que suponía para moscú el avance
de la alianza atlántica hacia el este
apenas tres meses después del inicio de
la guerra rusia puede ver como dos
países más se quieren sumar a la
organización uno de los cuales comparte
más de 1300 kilómetros de frontera
aunque es cierto que en la decisión
sobre si suecia y finlandia se unirán a
la otan tiene mucho que hablar turquía
la negativa de ankara y su posible veto
está comprometiendo la entrada de estas
dos naciones a la otan aunque la gran
mayoría de miembros de la organización
atlántica han dado su visto bueno a la
incorporación desde turquía existe un
recelo hacia la posición que tienen
estos dos países sobre el partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán una
organización considerada terrorista por
el gobierno turco lo que parece claro es
que pase lo que pase la decisión de
suecia y finlandia de perder su
neutralidad es un movimiento histórico
que ya está teniendo consecuencias
con esto concluimos gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]